1.2
very
[Music]
i'm definitely going to be coming back
to this house ragev falcao great to have
you in my house
on a wednesday thank you it's a pleasure
to be here you've got an incredible
story you went from literally nothing
holes in your shoes
out you know absolute outcast to now
having a three million pound property
portfolio with a net profit of half a
million pounds in there which is just
incredible so tell me how did this all
start how did you end up in the uk where
are you from what's your story
um i'm from israel
um
i came here about seven years ago i come
here as you say basically with nothing
with 50 pound and my little dog
i search myself for a while few months
here and there small jobs
until i've got an offer to
be a labor in the construction industry
okay i mean i didn't have so many other
options and i went
and worked
we happy
i was happy because i had a job and i
could pay my rent and eat how much how
much you're getting paid i used to get
70 pounds per day and and and pay a
small debt here in the uk for a friend
that used to help me pay my my rent yeah
i used to give him back 30 from this 70
every day so i basically used to make 40
pounds every day right and from there i
had to
grow and climb the ladder so that 40
pounds java expenses bus fare cigarettes
cigarettes yeah food
so you were you were living
um not not a not a luxurious life
not at all i used to rent a room in a in
an hmo house right yeah and
not only did you not have any money
you borrowed money off of people which
was bad debt how much it how much were
you in debt at this point when you're
working as a laborer so i came to
england with 100k depth
and then
i borrowed here around 3k for my friend
just every time a little bit more just
to survive just to hold myself
alive
and
[Music]
yeah it wasn't easy
but i was very happy to work
yeah
so i imagine there's a lot of people in
that same situation a lot of people say
that hard work leads to prosperity i
believe that hard work does not lead to
prosperity it's about working hard but
also about working smart at the same
time
so you were working really hard you told
me you were hard up holes in your shoes
bad back
what did life look like at that point
it was very very hard it was
the worst time of my life i mean i used
to look at the mirror i not even
recognize myself i never cried in my
life that was a period that i used to
cry a lot
it was an experience
but
the moment is it was behind me i i think
it's make me even stronger than what i
was and you know dog what's the dog's
name a jack it's a jack russell still
have it yeah he's 12 years old wow i'm
not gonna give it up like sometimes i
had to buy him food with not for myself
yeah and like
now
something remarkable happened when you
were working as a laborer because for a
start you got into rent and rents yes uh
tell me a little bit about that
so i was uh
looking for
more ways to to make an income as you
say as a labor it's not it's not taking
you nowhere
and every opportunity used to pass by us
to grab it with my two hands
so i had an opportunity i knew somebody
who bought a house but it was
[Music]
unhabitable
it was like few windows missing old
carpet painting
small stuff
but
i offered him to to rent the house for
for a year and a half and and to
renovate it myself but for a good good
price it was a thousand pound a month
and it was a big house
um and from the thousand pound i also
deduct the cost of the renovation that
it was six thousand pounds so basically
i left to pay 500 pounds a month in the
first year
and
i took the house
renovated very quickly and the same guy
that bought the house
it was the guy that i used to work for
in the construction so automatically i
just took
his employees and put them into the
house
and i used to make like 3k a month
wow yeah because the the room in in
north london are expensive you're
looking at like 800 900 room
and it was a big house so it's created a
very nice cash flow and with that money
you then started paying off your hundred
thousand pounds yeah debt yes now
when did you because your portfolio now
consists of by refurbishing finance
properties you've got a portfolio of
around three million pounds around
london which is incredible how you went
from that to that
when did you realize about biorefurbish
refinance and how did that happen so
when the corona started i was like
okay i will stay more at home and try
not to go to my teams of the
construction they still worked outside
but i was trying to stay as much as i
can home and
obviously you have a lot of time home
you want to
make something in this time so i was
searching
what can i do with the money i saved
in property so i think i googled the
house flips
and straight away you appeared there
with your video
and
i started to listen and it was the brr
video
i'm like oh my god
if this is actually
real
with my
construction company i can make it
happen and
yeah i start to search deals and when i
find the first one like that's it
that's it
another thing as well is you have a
really great energy about you your no no
one can meet you and forget you
and
you are great at pulling people together
so when you kind of got gripped on this
property vision
and we'll talk about it a little bit
later you've pulled in quite a lot of
people you've pulled in some amazing
joint venture partners that have helped
and teamed up with you to get where
you've got to
how important do you think it is
to collaborate with others rather than
trying to do everything alone
it's very important i mean in this in
this work there is so many
angles uh like i mean you need to have
good lawyers you need to have
if it's in the construction so your
builders your architect your engineer
all the power team around you
um obviously you need it you cannot do
it without it yeah also you
were the fastest person ever to get
through the deal finding extravaganza
course
the fastest ever i mean you don't mess
about no i think i think that my biggest
value is is that i'm a man of action yes
massive massive massive action even
today when all my equity is
invested i'm going and i put in offers
on house like okay 1.3 million no
problem offer of i put in offers when i
get offer accepted then i start to run
search for the investor so yeah i take
the action into a different level that's
really important though because
that's i think that's the thing that
most people will lack most people are
trying to work out the xyz
rather than just walking the abc whereas
you're the opposite yeah you'll just run
through the abc
without knowing really what you're doing
but you'll just figure it out as you go
you'll ask for help when needed you've
come around my house yeah you know you
spent the day with me i think last year
yeah um you've done you've done the deal
phone extravaganza the samuel 365.
but at the same time you don't try and
figure out every bit of detail you know
you just take massive action which again
is another really really important
lesson so tell me about your first
brr deal how did it come about what are
the figures taught me through the deal
so in many of the videos that i watched
it's mentioned that it's very hard to do
brr in london
so i i started to search also i was a
first time buyer i never had a property
in the uk so i knew
i should um
pass to the ladder of the
buy to let
with being a landlord i didn't know any
other ideas at the time so i was like
okay i will buy a small property just to
be a landlord
and okay so i start to search for small
properties and then i realize this is a
one-bedroom flat in ground floor
it's a masonite it's been split before
but i can still do the extension i can
still
do the same work like i'm doing for any
other house
and
then it will be three bedrooms like hmo
what will be the value then start to do
the calculation and i realize wow it's
100 meter for my house and it can be
done here in in edward even though
because of my cost price are lower
because i'm the contractor
it's all it's all come together yes so
like okay that's my first deal i went to
my um broker
he's one of my customers i knew he's a
mortgage broker and i went there to have
an advice and when he saw my deals he
offered to join in
uh and to go straight away on two of
them because we are two so you went to
the mortgage broker to ask for
traditional finance yes you haven't got
a property you'd never bought a property
no you're from israel but your mortgage
break broker said you found such a good
deal forget
me trying to get you a mortgage i'll
come in on the deal myself yeah and
we've done two straight away that's
incredible yeah it shows the power as
well of not just
getting the good people around you
taking massive action but also the power
of finding a good deal yes i would say
if you find a good deal the finance will
come yes it's true it's true
you found a really really good deal
and then after that i stayed with uh
like 75 75k equity in my hand was like
okay that will be enough for
half investment for another deal
where can i get another 75k so a fan
tell me listen there is a good bridger
uh here in the community go and ask for
75k so when i get there
he saw the deal and he was like why you
need to get the bridge i can join in
with you as well all right let's go for
it yes
so and again a lot of people will say i
can't get the finance uh i'm from a
different country i'm a first-time buyer
so i can't but instead of trying to find
the problems what you did was she found
the opportunities you found the deals
and then you made a way you forced when
the doors were shutting in your face you
were kicking them open yes which is
which is which is what oh i had a lot of
difficulties like i had one of those
properties
the the mortgage offer was delaying and
the seller
um decided he don't want to sell anymore
because he got like other agencies come
to him and tell him you're selling it
too cheap because i really squeezed the
price nicely there
and he
he canceled the deal
i was very disappointed but after one
month the agent called me he was like
he's the deal is back on the table but
he won't take 10k more
i was like all right no problem we have
a deal and we bought it
and how much how much you pay for it so
this one i pay 370 yeah
10k stem duty yeah and 60k renovation so
all in all 440
sec okay
and
the the project was taking uh
first floor mason eighth house so it's
basically half a house it's a flat
um and from two bedroom i
went up to the loft and make it three
bedrooms
obviously removing some walls make open
plan very modern and make it very very
high spec yeah
and
like three weeks ago the bank evaluated
in 600. wow yeah that's 160 grand equity
profit yeah or 100 out with refinance
right yeah both basically it's 100 out
plus like 160k equity on the house and
that's what you've been choosing to do
you've been pulling out your money how
many how many deals like this have you
done over the last year or so i've done
four deals like that that one of them is
a whole house that i split into two so
it's basically five properties five
properties
and have you are you refinancing them
all or have you already now i'm in a
process because all started i ran on
them in the renovation all together yeah
so are they all rented out all rented
out i actually wait wait for the six
months period to start the refinance yes
because i make the renovation very quick
how many of the five are you having to
leave any money in
none of them you're putting all your all
the money back that's incredible i mean
that's the deals i'm looking for from
the beginning now after i got all those
valuations from the banks i know the
exact numbers i also work in a very
specific area yeah so i don't know to do
the i don't need to do the all the due
diligence
all over again and all over again i know
the numbers everything is clear i just
need to buy it in the proper price
and i'm good to go a lot of the training
that you did with me was online because
you did this during lockdown exactly so
you did the deal funny extravaganza you
did all of the everything crash course
yeah i know
any video of yours by heart
[Laughter]
what was what was the training like
um i love it i mean i i felt like it's
like feeding my soul because i know i'm
in the right place yeah i knew i need to
gain as much as more
uh
knowledge yeah
it's a
game of big money this for me
and i wanted to reduce the the risks as
much as possible
and getting as much as more golden
nuggets yeah from everywhere i could
also the day the lockdown was lifted the
very same day i opened my house up and i
said i'm opening my house up anyone
wants to come it's 500 pounds
come down and we'll spend the day
together and and it's going to be
intimate because it's just in my house
and you were the first person that
booked on yeah what made you book on and
what happened i mean i won't miss a good
opportunity as i say a man of action
there is an option to meet i'm coming
at the moment i didn't i at the time i
didn't know you personally like that's
the right moment that that's the time to
meet when was that that must have been
about a year ago that was a year ago
went back into a lot now i think it was
a bit more maybe than a year ago because
i completed on the first property
a year no it's exactly a year ago right
it's exactly a year ago so
talk to me then your properties now if
you add them all up the value is around
three million pounds yes and you've got
quite a lot of equity about half a
million pounds my side i mean in the
whole three million there is a million
pound equity right yeah your profit is
half a million yeah going from
a few years back coming to coming to
england with nothing a hundred thousand
pounds worth of debt
you arrived seven years ago in england
you're working on 40 pounds a day holes
in your shoes
to now
having three million pound worth of
property i mean
how does that feel
it's it's feel good
it's feel it's surreal it's
it's give me some relaxation but from
the other hand when you come from the
place that you are so low
it's it's leaving you with some mental
uh scratches issues or
and you're always afraid to be there
again
so it's hard to
go and jump and dance and
and
you know be over over the top because of
it i prefer to first reach my goals
and then i will celebrate my goals are
way more
yeah okay well you said to me um when we
were speaking off-camera i was like wow
you've done amazing you've made so much
money you also per month you're now
making pretty decent money yeah how much
you making up the money well all of them
together at the moment is like 6k so
yeah which is which is a really good
wage yes it is i mean it's and it's
passive yeah
it's it's the it's the cash flow yeah
yeah
so six thousand pounds a month passive
cash flow yeah plus half a million
pounds of personal equity for you yeah
yes i mean you're almost i mean a cash
millionaire you will be very soon and
you said to me you said samuel don't
forget though i'm still the underdog
i'll always i will always be the
underdog and you're saying you're almost
a cash millionaire but i'm the most
broke cash millionaire at the moment in
the world why are you because i invest
everything back
all back into you yes yes i don't want
to hold anything in my pocket at the
moment as much as i can make it grow and
grow and grow until i reach my target
yeah i'm fine with being simple i don't
need to be a cash millionaire okay in
some ways you're very exuberant with
your money
you're like for instance you're like oh
500 pounds to come and meet sammy in his
house i'll do it you know
oh i'll make money i'll throw it back
into my properties i'll throw it into it
in some ways you're very exuberant with
your money but then in other ways you're
very very frugal yeah you're very tight
talk to me about the things that you're
tight and frugal and reserved with your
money and the things that you're saying
no i don't i don't think i'm tight i
mean
my my my average living cost is like
6k in london i mean kiddie garden 1000
pounds
flat is 2 000 pounds uh two cars is a
thousand pound and food and it's a 6k so
i wouldn't say and we taking holidays
and we do we have whatever we need and
want
you're not that broke then you said you
you were the broken
yeah but i've seen better days with cash
flows in my pocket so i say i'm like
kind of a broke but
not a millionaire i don't think you're
that broke no not a bro
i always find a joke that like i'm a
broke rich guy yeah yeah yeah but
and also you've pulled in
your solicitors your mortgage broker
your bridging why do all these people
want to invest in your deals what are
you saying that's making them want to
invest
so my added value basically is that i'm
offering to my investor is that i'm
doing the building cost price through
our sharing company yeah and let's
create straight away
big chunk of the equity at the end of
the project right so that's the add
value that i bring with me at top of i
bring the i source the deal i manage the
deal i do the whole thing
and
so it's about what you're bringing to
the table you might not have had much
money to start with
but you had the construction knowledge
the skills you had the time you had the
ability to find the deals off the back
of the videos and the training so you're
bringing quite a lot to the table all
they're bringing to the table is putting
the money in yeah in the first three
property i invest together with them
yeah
the first two that i've done with my
first investor um
i invest with him and it was my climbing
on the ladder
like to be
from first time buyer to buy to let so
in jv it's a good it's a good
solution for this situation yeah
um
what are you working on right now
at the moment i'm i having an external
work i'm building a school in hendon
and i also
at the end of my big project finishes
the house that i'm splitting into two
flats
it's very
exciting and
all of them in mill hill it's like
luxurious area in north london
right next to edward where where i live
and that's it that's my area so what you
do with this school that sounds really
exciting yeah in the school it's kind of
like few years project every time they
add in more and more into the school
more classes more areas and now we
started a
big project there that we actually gonna
raise two more floors into the schools
they're going to make a wedding hall
above it and a few more classes
it includes metal structure and
it's something nice it's interesting i
understand why from someone that was
working as a laborer for 40 pounds a day
why you'd want to put the work in to
make more money but now you've got to a
point where you're making great money
you've got a big portfolio but you're
still just as hungry as ever what is it
that drives you what's the what's the
reason behind all this
i think maybe because i quit school when
i was young when i was 15 i always had
the feeling that
don't don't stay behind
no one
and run in front of everyone and i think
this is my motivation in life and this
is what's
trigger my massive action i mean i don't
want to stay behind yeah did you feel
that
you failed in school
i wasn't fail i was like it was some i'm
kind of a person that likes to do
whatever he chose to do yeah i
i guess i born with it
so i used to start like the first
semester like excellent and then in the
middle one it was like what's going on
with you and the third one they
like you're not staying with us for next
year yeah so yeah it wasn't that i
wasn't good it's just i didn't like it
or i didn't have the patient or
or the focus
what do you love about property so much
oh in properties i love everything i
love everything first of all the the
bill they start for me from the build
side so it's the build side is
interesting is profitable
and
[Music]
also from the investment side i mean who
don't want to leave a legacy for his
family for his kids something to
stay
after me do you have kids i have a
little girl how old is she she's two
years old congratulations thank you very
much her name is emily
i would also would like to to
take advantage of this stage say thank
you to my wife
um because when i met her
i was broke and she believed in me
she
took me from the floor you know it's
like
my screen in my phone broke i didn't
even have money to to go and fix it or
how to call to search for a job this is
how she
took me and this is how she believed in
me and
respect for her for that bad respect yes
having a supportive partner behind you
is the most underrated thing it's so
great to have someone behind you that's
something definitely she's my partner
how does she feel about what's happened
she's 100
supportive
she's giving me all the freedom in the
world to do whatever i think is right
she never
like
um
disagree with with my move yeah with
your ambition
very ambition what was it about me that
made you decide to come and train with
me
you have the best energy i mean like all
the other guys are boring you can fall
asleep when you listen to them
you you have the energy it's it's
i mean listen to you it's it's it's
coming it's like when you have a boring
teacher and a very exciting teacher it's
just the same
and i felt the connection also because
you have quite similar story than me
like you quit school when you was young
you are a believer and i think we have
many points in comments
and yeah you are my man well i'm
absolutely
over the moon for what you've achieved
thank you so much you should be i think
now is the time to celebrate what you've
done yes as well as looking forward to
what's coming what would you say to
somebody watching this that's maybe in a
situation whereby there might be 35 like
you were when you started they've got
nothing and they're thinking is this
really possible or is this just a pipe
dream what would your what would you say
to them
so
first of all yes
it is possible
um
i will tell them
to believe in themselves
i believe them
to take mercy i will tell them to take
massive massive action
not to be afraid i mean
you'll gain your your confidence with
the success of your moves but if you
won't do your move it's not going to
happen
so
i started 35 years old with a disc slide
in my back
like i used to go and dig in the ground
with the shovel that was horrible but in
my mind was
you go
you continue forward continue forward
it's a period of time it will pass
everything will be just fine and you
need to continue and really
if i can
inspire even one guy to
to go out from the hole
and climb up the ladder i've done mine
i'm happy yeah i'm happy to do that and
i love that you've reached not in your
opinion but in many people's opinions
you've reached the top
i know you think that you've not reached
the top yet but you've reached the top
but you're trying to pull other people
up inspire other people always i love
that about you always i mean if somebody
tell me i want to learn and it's
happened i put them next to me as a
mentor but a mentor that is
taking them
with him all day long during the day
they hear my conversation they see the
work they say
that that's a pleasure to do like i love
him because a lot of people ask me you
know why do you teach people why do you
open your house up and it's hard to
really explain
because until until you've had some
success
you don't know what you'd be like but
after becoming successful myself i get
the same buzz seeing you win and seeing
other people win as i did see myself
when yeah i mean i'm the underdog will
always be so when i have an underdog
that is like from my point of view he is
with me is in my level i want to help
him to be a big underdog
upper dog
you are an underdog and you always will
be because of where you've come from
what you've had to do yeah but
you have never been a victim
no and there's a big difference
sometimes people think i'm an underdog
but then they use that as an excuse not
to do stuff and they think they're a
victim oh i'm here i've got no money
i've got this dare it's not my fault
blameless no no no you've never been
that way no i can actually take even
responsibility i came here broke yeah
because i
over leverage myself in my own country
yeah so i've done something there
but uh
it's left me broke
yeah so a lot of people as well that i'm
coaching i feel like when people have
got it all together and they're making
70 grand a year they've got two cars
they've got a corporate job a wife that
expects two holidays a year three kids
they are it's harder for them to make it
than it is for people like you that have
nothing because when you've got nothing
you've also got nothing to lose
yes it's true it's true but when i
started the the
investment
i had something to lose i already saved
my equity i mean
i didn't start it from zero i start with
like between 150 and 200k when i start
to invest yeah it took me years to save
it i had the goals each time next goal
next goal okay now i will reach this
number an hour this number till that
time so i always was in the track about
my finance and about my my
my pot yeah
but but in making that money though
you still have risks because in doing
the rent to rent for example that could
have made you in even more debt but
that's true you took a risk but you did
it in a way which was like this has to
work yes yes i won't give up no it's
like
i
i will push anything i'm doing till the
the the the point it's working yeah and
that's it there's no other option for me
the money that you made from rent to
rent even was ridiculous yes it was
crazy yeah one property 3k
amount a month
and you just saved it yeah i just saved
it and it helped me to sort out my depth
in israel yeah well listen massive
congrats thank you so much samuel thank
you so much it's a pleasure i appreciate
you coming into my house coming on the
show sharing the story thank you very
much and i'm sure one day we'll do some
deals together oh yeah definitely
awesome
[Music]
you